the writers on this season of America
are getting a little heavy-handed
getting a little bit on the nose you see
in this season that we're all living
through the libs are no longer only
implicitly worshiping Satan they are
overtly explicitly worshiping Satan as
the singer Sam Smith showed us during
the Grammys
you see he's there's fire there's a
bunch of uh transsexuals prancing around
there's there's Sam Smith has horns and
a devil costume on but that's not the
best part
you gotta wait for it okay Applause
cameras zooming out
the Grammys brought to you by Pfizer
you you can't you can't possibly make
that up there it is it's too much it's
too silly it's too absurd
it's too real